Herr Thoma
die neuen Märkte etwas Puder kündigt
jetzt voll freihändig
und es gab keine Pläne bezüglich in
Polen aufzutreten Schritt konkreter
geworden sind
unter der gleichen Firma diese Pläne
unterstützt also ich meine Plattenfirma
hat
bevor dieses Amt im Frühjahr auf dem
polnischen Markt für Tausende
und um ich wusste um das zwölffache
auch Auftritte geben also
Wien die Sprecherin
noch zwei Wochen stattgefunden aber es
wird auf jeden Fall
die harte Kritik aktuelle Preise einig
und warten ob es stimmt dass wir dieses
Jahr für Jahr ein Projekt wie wir es
ähnlich
und in welcher Sprache die viele sein
Na also
das Fragen rund um schon möglich Foto
dpa Kirchbergs ist wenn das «Bitte
bleiben früher aus Koblenz
ich denke mit einem polnischen Sommer
auf dem Platz Schlag abbekommen Dr
der deutsche Markt war
Angreifer Heidelberg dpa
für uns die nächste Frage nicht
erkennen
ob die weiterhin mit Robert Godley
zusammenarbeitet mit sorgen unten
Foto Wünsch ihrem Büchlein gerne
fortsetzen das ist ein sehr sehr cooler
Prozent
da und wird
selber Maskottchen rund um das Wahlrecht
wahnsinnig viel viel Spaß Guillaume
bereits jetzt um mich mit diesem treffen
und so lustig oder
Staufen musikalischen Ebene
auszutauschen ist das
ja auch viel Wert und nutzen und Anton
Erfahrungen cooler Typ
immer wieder gerne
dann ist die Frage was machen die
und bei Audi die IV zufrieden mit den
Kameras den ersten Preis in Katar von
Reggie
selbst ab 2
München 18 im Herbst wurde abgewehrt
eine Aussprache ganz gut zufrieden war
bisher haben schon beim Kauf anbieten
angeschoben
Entwickler können so viele Gedanken um
7 Prozent nach oben schossen
Spieltag sind
in der Lernfunktion Landes und und
musikalischem auch im Vorjahr
umgesetzten zugemacht
Gruppen für Spaß gemacht
Künste der FWG verhelfen Leder Exempel
bisschen erfolgreicher zu sein
Versicherten offen angeboten
um bei der Mutter auf doch Ammann
Soloprojekt Sankt einfach nur in Ruhe
Chaplins gehen können sondern an
gesunden
Precht und um
warum ich habe dann auch angeboten
einfach auch mal Prozent auf Konzerte in
Deutschland zu spielen
der Druck war groß
Bauern müssen mal gucken wie wir es
jetzt also
zumal so
die gelassene Wege leiten